let's talk brittany yes britney is
writing a tell-all did you hear i heard
let me let me pre-order right now all
right i want to read that book i want to
read that book today here's the deal she
signed a uh deal with simon schuster
which is the division of our parent
company oh that's paramount so that
means you'll get your book earlier
it will focus on the pop star's rise to
fame her career and her family reports
say there was a bidding war for the book
and the deal was you believe that
fifteen million dollars that's what the
deal is reported worth this comes just
three months after an la judge ended a
long-running conservatorship giving
spears more control over her life we
reached out to the publisher and the
spears attorney for comment we have not
yet are dating back right back they
didn't get right back to us no because i
want to hear what she has to say i think
everybody is i really do she's promising
me and i'm glad she's writing it she's
been talking recently on social media
shout outs to her family really speaking
her mind i've been taking shots she said
on instagram lord have mercy on my
family's souls if i ever do an interview
i mean is that a tease or is that a
tease can't wait can't wait